this is the downtown las vegas event
center and concerts return their alex
tomorrow night
i know this is huge so music producer
dead mouse kicks off a two weekend
series of insomniac events on
friday hector mejia is live with how
organizers are preparing to host some
really big crowds again
hey hector it's so exciting to talk
about this
it really is and it feels kind of
surreal seeing everything from start to
finish from the shutdown to now seeing
things reopen
so we're at the downtown las vegas
events center where as you just
mentioned this big concert is happening
tomorrow
way out there in the distance that's the
main entrance after concert goers get
checked in
and they present proof of either their
vaccination status or their negative
tests they'll be able to roam around
free out here across the grounds way up
up there that's probably hopefully where
we'll be sitting watching the dead mouse
concert tomorrow night and it's tomorrow
at 7 p.m
and take a look at this an outdoor
concert i mean an
outdoor stage you know we have not seen
this in more than a year
and joining us live we have mike to
explain how they're preparing to host
large crowds again how they plan to stay
efficient good morning to you
yes good morning hector thanks again for
coming down so early this morning to
talk about our
exciting event tomorrow night with with
all the people that we
anticipate coming down we've we've gone
above and beyond we hope uh to make sure
that we have efficient lines
so as you come down you can show your
proof of vaccination all your negative
pcr covet tests
we can get your wristband credential to
get you in and also with that being said
today starting at noon our box office
opens
so we can also do that early if you
already have your credentials come on
down
we can get your wrist banded get it
taken care of today as well as tomorrow
three
mike so you know after not having a
concert an event here for
14 months how are you guys getting ready
to put up to put on a show again
so yeah we've spent probably the better
part of a month or so
just refitting everything getting
everything repaired
fixed all the new stuff put in and we
actually do have some new uh
unique little uh hidden secrets out of
production which we can't talk about yet
we're talking about yeah but you can see
it tomorrow night definitely starting at
seven
and with that being said last night we
first we finally got the chance to
actually
hear our full uh main speakers up here
on the stage and it was just a stage
coming alive was just
one of the best feelings we've had in a
long time how incredible was that
it really was it was just the feeling
the excitement of just
our whole team internally to actually
hear the stage come alive
it's been amazing and we couldn't have
done all this
without all the help from our leadership
our owners our executives insomniac our
partners
and especially the clark county
commission awesome well thank you for
having us here early to talk about this
and to preview what's happening tomorrow
still ahead at the top of the hour at
six o'clock we'll talk about what else
is coming here
to this space as they get ready to host
people humans
all over again reporting live from
downtown hector mejia
8 news now